the problem I think is when having sex
like a man is seen as a default setting
because it doesn't suit the interests of
most women if we're saying that
something that suits the interests of
let's say five percent of women should
be the norm that inevitably is going to
mean that 95 percent are nudged by Shame
by social pressure the book in general
is intended as a critique of liberal
feminism and sometimes criticized by
conservatives and Christians for not
being conservative and Christian enough
I work for a campaign group called we
can't consent to this what we do is we
document cases where UK women have been
killed and their Killers have claimed in
court that they consented to the
violence which led to their deaths so
like the sex game gone wrong I think
that the focus on consent as the sole
framework for determining whether or not
sexual behavior is good or bad is
completely inadequate there's so much
gray area between good sex and
consensual sex